[موسيقى]
أنت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أراك
هذه أسوأ صحة عامة
لجيل يقارنها
البعض بالأنفلونزا الموسمية للأسف وهذا ليس صحيحًا
بسبب نقص المناعة ضد هذا
المرض  E أكثر
خطورة وستنتشر أكثر ويجب أن
تتساوى معك في نفس المستوى مع الجمهور البريطاني
، حيث ستفقد المزيد من العائلات والعديد من
العائلات أحبائها
قبل وقتهم ،
لذلك هذا هو ما يبدو عليه أن تكون في
الحجر الصحي قليلاً  القليل من الجنون
في جميع الجولات لحسن الحظ ، لدينا
نظام دعم مذهل في مجتمعنا ،
لدينا الكثير من الأشخاص
الذين يساعدون ويتأكدون من أن لدينا
طعامًا جيدًا ، وأعتقد أنه من المهم جدًا
فهم ماهية منطقة الاحتواء
وما هو ليس كذلك  ليست منطقة حظر ،
إنها ليست منطقة حجر صحي
، لا يُمنع الأشخاص من دخول
المنطقة أو مغادرتها ،
فهي لا تؤثر على الأفراد باستثناء
أولئك الذين يخضعون
لحجر صحي خاص بهم
[موسيقى]
إنها أكتوا  لقد كان مرهقًا بشكل لا يصدق ،
لكن كان من المدهش حقًا أن
المدرسة نفسها كانت رائعة
وموقع O الذي تم إنشاؤه للتأكد من
أننا أطفال نتعلم
طوال اليوم بشكل أساسي وفقًا لجدول المدرسة ،
إنه أمر رائع كل نصف ساعة ، حيث
توجد أنشطة مختلفة
يجتمع فيها المعلمون  الدردشات وجهاً لوجه عند التكبير / التصغير ، إنها
رائعة جدًا وأننا نحبها تمامًا
ويجد الأطفال هذه عطلة
رائعة ، ونأمل أن تنتهي هذه الإجازة
قريبًا وسأكون قادرًا على الخروج والتنقل
وأكون قادرًا على الاعتناء
أنا وعائلتي وآمل
أن يكون الجميع بصحة جيدة
[موسيقى]